welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and it's an
absolutely incredible time to be a DC
fan as we have some amazing news that's
just come in within the last hour The
Hollywood Reporter has dropped a new
story that says Michael Keaton will be
reprising his role as Batman in the
upcoming flashpoint movie starring Ezra
Miller yes
Michael Keaton throughout this video
we're gonna be going through the ins and
outs of the story and discussing
everything we know about it I've also
got some stuff that I need to address in
regards to our last Batman video but
I'll talk about that at the end and just
go over the state of play with you in
regards to leaks and so on now there may
be some spoilers here so if you don't
anything potentially Roone about the
upcoming DC projects then I highly
recommend that you turn off now make
sure you subscribe to the channel for
videos like this every day
and please drop a thumbs up if you're as
hyped as we are without the way thank
you for clicking this now let's get to
our breakdown of the Michael Keaton
casting news okay so late last week
there were reports going around that
Jeffrey Dean Morgan was going to be
playing Thomas Wayne aka Batman in the
upcoming flashpoint movie in case you
don't know flashpoint in the comics
involves the flash traveling through
time to save his mother from being
murdered but this causes a lot of
repercussions including the death of
Bruce Wayne and Crime Alley this leads
to his father becoming Batman and its
mother becoming the Joker so Morgan who
had already played Tommy in the DC EU
seemed like a perfect shoo-in
however The Hollywood Reporter have just
come out with a story that says the
following there may be a new Batman in
town and he's the same as the old Batman
Michael Keaton who famously starred as
the Caped Crusader and the Tim Burton
directed early 1990s Batman movies is in
talks to reprise the character for
Warner Brothers DC movie the flash if a
deal makes Keaton wooden just returned
for flash but possibly several other DC
orientated film projects sources tell
thr that the role being envisioned for
the veteran actor is akin to the role
played by samuel l.jackson as Nick Fury
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
something of a mentor or guide or even
string
Batgirl is one of the projects in
development that could fall under that
win so this is absolutely incredible
news and as I'm sure you can tell I'm
over the moon to see the guy who I view
is Batman returning growing up Keaton
was my favorite and whether it was the
car costume or just the general style of
his portrayal he completely nailed the
role in my eyes I was actually born in
1988 and Batman came out in 1989 and I'm
sure that it was one of the first films
I ever watched I remember my mother
taped it for me and I just completely
lost there watching that film it was
incredible probably shouldn't have been
watching it at three years old or
whatever but you know life was different
back then you could watch Robocop and
have a laugh now this will mean that we
could potentially have three versions of
Batman over the next couple of years
with Affleck in the Schneider cut
Pattinson doing his own thing and Keaton
coming back either way it sounds amazing
and if he does come in as a mentor a
Kent in ik fury I think it would just be
incredible to see also yeah how big is
this story that it just completely
overshadows the Batgirl announcement I
love you too Batgirl but yeah this is
this is just absolutely huge I actually
watch spider-man homecoming this week to
do a breakdown video on it which you
should definitely check out and yeah
once more I was just completely blown
away by King's performance in the role
he just has a darker side to him and if
you familiar with the betrayal of Thomas
Wayne and flashpoint then you'll
definitely know that's needed obviously
this is just incredible news but I will
keep you up to date on it as the story
develops
now as for our other part the video that
we need to address I need to clear
something up now my last Batman video
contained three bits of news including a
final part that was breaking down a
leaked script that I'd been sent since
reporting on it I did send it to
numerous people behind the scenes and
Twitter account that sauce discovered
that it was in fact a fake script that
was taken from a YouTube video on how to
write a John wick action scene the names
and locations had been changed however
after reading it it was clearly the same
script and as I hadn't seen the video
though
absolutely no way of me knowing it so I
just want to hold my hands up and admit
that I got it wrong and I did feel like
a complete idiot after posting it
because yeah it doesn't look good for
the channel for me to be reporting on
things like that when they turn out to
be untrue now as for the rest of the
leaks in that video from what I've heard
from multiple sources they are correct
however I know for definite that this
script isn't so all of the elements
about the iceberg lounge and combat are
fake I'm as disappointed as I can be
over it and I've decided that because of
this going forward to make sure that
credibility on the channel remains and
you guys aren't lied to I'm not gonna be
reporting on any leaks that I can't
verify with proof it just keeps
everything aboveboard and you know I
feel like I've let you guys down I get a
lot of comments on my videos about how
people you know I'm a source that people
trust so putting this kind of stuff out
it doesn't make me feel good about
myself I've been thinking about the best
way to address this and I was gonna do a
big video on it tomorrow but you know as
this news has just come out I thought
I'd just add it on here and then I can
clear it up as quickly as possible and
then we can do nothing but good news
tomorrow I will still be doing that big
DC video but yeah it's just gonna be
good news and I needed to get this out
of the way because it's been really
doing my head in the last week thing and
I know that script no real so yet
hopefully you can forgive me and yeah
even with this bad news I'm still
excited as hell for Keaton to return now
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the casting news and if you're as
excited as I am make sure you comment
below and let us know and if you enjoy
this video then please drop a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of last week's Batman news
which is gonna be linked at the end just
make sure you don't watch that bit about
the script at the end because it's a
load of crap now if you want to support
the channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early
you wanna come chatters after the show
either follow us at heavy spoilers or
click the discord link in the
description below every month we give
away free movies to be bla subscribe
channel and this Monty come on the MCU
infinity saga box set and all you have
to do is comment on a video and make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
the more videos you comment on the more
you've a chance of winning so make sure
you get involved the winners gonna be
chosen at random on the 15th of July in
the cell be shipped out from then to
ever gets the price it's the best of
luck to everyone who takes part thanks
for sticking around till the end I'll
see you next time
take care and have a good night
[Music]